non content qu'on se voit vite parce que
c'est un peu le chantier avec la fusion
donc l'idée pour que tu te calmes le
plus tôt possible sur mon organisation
ah non je dis lui l'idée pour tu te
calmes le plus tôt possible sur le court
je lai si je peux me permettre c'est toi
qui débarque dans ma boîte
c'est à toi de calais au nom malaise il
a fêté prix je suis en fait passer mon
service là donc je suis ton supérieur
hiérarchique
non c'est moi ton supérieur n'a pas été
brisé
écoute je comprends que ça soit complète
pour toi la ccvo locaux je le comprends
très bien simplement moi on m'a
clairement dit que je chapeaute le
service chapeaute chapeaute on chope
chapote je suis au comex c'est moi qui
suis un peu de tout mais moi je suis au
codir donc je chipote mais comex codir
et non et si et non codir comme accent
si le stratégik l'opérationnel
même si c'est quoi en fait se détendre
un peu je suis très détendu et ouais on
va manger un morceau tous deux plutôt
crever non j'ai déjà mangé
merci à alicia c'est bien qu'il soit là
tu peux nous sortir le l'organigramme de
la boîte soit fait pour toi
bonjour mais qu'est ce qui me fait
réaliser jusqu'à l'iss ben ali ce qui
est mon assistante non non non on n'a
vraiment pas la même culture
d'entreprise chez nous personne n'est
assistant ali ses collaboratrices
délégué à la drh alors collaboratrice
délégué à la drh la drh et moi et moi
aussi
non non non c'est pas possible ça
n'existe pas à les boîtes avec de drh je
sais pas tu dois être rh ou un truc
comme ça là là c'est mon nom tu vois et
derrière ses marques et drh veut rien
dire sans écouter les cris douche sur
les sur les chambres à gaz
non enfin je veux dire c'est pas parce
que c'est écrit quelque part que c'est
vrai allez allez rebondi et on et vous
donne tous un peu juif c'est toute façon
non un ok c'est la saiema c'est le
moment de simuler un avc non enfin je
t'assure rh drh aussi d'accord de drh
voilà on met deux drh moi je suis votre
assistante à tous les deux non non non
non non pas raison tu es notre
collaboratrice délégué à tous les deux à
orly ory
aurélie aurélie aurélie pas drori
veulent et amélie amélie vous pouvez
peut-être nous aider là comment comment
ça marche ici la hiérarchie je veux dire
c'est que c'est qu'il n'entraîne plus en
[Rires]
plus de 2 au dessus dessous de 2
verticales horizontales quoi même si
c'est cette diagonale diagonale
diagonale carrément ben voyons c'est
quoi le prochain terme à la course
spirale diagonale on est tous égaux
asseyez vous en faites ce que vous
attendez de nous c'est de la fraîcheur
c'est des méthodes en fait personne ne
voit clair dans son jeu là c'est moi le
mec bien on est dans une phase de
polarisation dynamique très bien ce que
tu veux
amélie amélie un plan social non non non
d ans la sauvegarde de l'emploi taille
juste un tout petit pour que la loi
puisse s'épanouir à l'essai pour salles
et aux drh rats les ils veulent
qu on dégraisse et ils nous mettent en
compet pour sa halle et aux coups de
boutoir pas laisser gagner
je me lève je fais comme lui ça ne met
en valeur je vais rester à 2009 et la
[Musique]
voilà voilà c'est ça oui mais là lâche
un peu d'aplomb c'est clair oui oui
c'est clair s'il arrive ça lui même est
très sympa hein monsieur merde
alice tu veux des jeunes avec moi 1 je
vais proposer il a déjà mangé tab on m'a
mis à bas du non dit nous bah oui bah
oui avec plaisir
bon bah je passe tout rentrait je
reviens petit jeu dix minutes deux fois
tu des jeunes deux fois voilà je veux
des jeunes est deux fois
[Musique]